hi my name is Stephanie Wong and today
we're going to explore how bigquery
google clouds fully managed enterprise
data warehouse enables you to run
analytics at scale using standard sequel
with zero operational overhead it
provides unique functionality like
real-time stream ingestion query
Federation GIS functions and built in
machine learning capabilities and to
bring this to life let's look at how new
kicks a fictional brick-and-mortar and
online retailer uses advanced analytics
and bigquery to optimize their supply
chain the challenge started when the
director of marketing wanted to make
better ad targeting decisions the task
was given to the lead data scientist and
data engineer and they recognized for
challenges to overcome first up was to
break down the various data silos within
their organization
the data engineer at new cakes built out
a 1 to n mapping of key data sources
including Google Analytics Raw click
stream online transactional and in-store
inventory data that all moved data into
bigquery store operations data is stored
in the transactional database cloud
sequel these data sources were ingested
via a combination of bigquery data
transfer service and cloud data flow in
batch and streaming mode let's take a
look at this in action this is the cloud
dataflow console showing new kicks
real-time ETL for in-store transactions
stock levels and click stream data this
job ran tandem with batch and data
transfer jobs to hydrate various data
sets in the data warehouse the click
stream step was processing around 200
events per second with bigquery as a
target output this data was immediately
available for querying for example this
query shows the most recent click stream
events note the latest event is about
two seconds behind current UTC time with
real-time access to multiple data sets
they could perform more meaningful
analysis like this query joining online
sales with in store sales data
calculating ranks for the top 10
sneakers accessibility across various
warehouses makes a data more actionable
however after reviewing current schemas
in the data warehouse the data scientist
and data engineer realized they needed
to perform some additional and possibly
heavy transformation and enrichment in
order to get the right data sets in
place
and then we're going to need some
additional processing resources to get
the job done now to drive key data
warehouse workloads like ingestion ETL
and business intelligence new kicks use
a combination of bigquery pricing models
on demand and flat rate to optimize
resources and cost for lower query
volume workloads like query prototyping
and exploratory analysis the IT manager
utilized on-demand pricing with project
level cost controls however the
forecasting project presented new
challenges like unknown query volume
with the need to minimize disruption to
existing production workloads in
addition resources were only needed for
a few days this is where the power and
value of flex lots came into play flex
sauce let you purchase bakery capacity
for short durations as little as 60
seconds at a time using the bigquery UI
or the client libraries the IT manager
was able to immediately allocate 500
flex slots to a new project that the
data scientist and data engineer could
work in the server list nature of
bigquery enables deploying this
additional capacity in a few seconds and
can be shut down after 60 seconds so
it's an excellent solution for short
term and bursty workloads with their
additional and isolated capacity in
place the team started to make quick
work on transformation and enrichment to
drive the forecasting model the team
needed to produce a filtered and
enriched click stream that had several
key attributes including customer
location specific target action and
store location this required a series of
transformations including filtering
joining and applying GIS functions all
of which can be accomplished at scale in
bigquery to perform these
transformations new KK's data scientists
executed a series of query jobs inside
of AI platform notebooks which
streamlined integration with bakery the
goal here was to produce a filtered
click stream that was joined to customer
and in-store pickup data the first query
job filtered out clicks that meet a
specific requirement including active
sessions that ended with a purchase and
an in-store pickup this query reduces
the analysis set from 10 terabytes to
one terabyte notice that the results
were saved back as a new destination
table next the customer table was
enriched with geo coordinates which were
joined back to the clickstream she then
joined clay stream to orders to obtain
the geo information for his store
she used
an external query function to execute a
query into the store operations database
located on cloud sequel this type of
query a federation reduces data copying
with geo information for customers and
stores she applied one final
transformation and filter using built-in
GIS functions she could calculate the
distance between customer residents and
store location built in GIS functions
enable you to project analysis in line
without having to export your data
this query produces candidate feature
inputs for the model if she wants to
audit this process she can walk back
through the tables created over time
these queries could become materialized
views and or stream or batch transforms
setting the foundation for a feature
story with the transform data in place
they were able to move on to modeling so
they turned to big query ml if you have
experience with machine learning you
know that traditional workflows require
additional pre-processing data splitting
model development and deployment steps
but with big query ml steps like
pre-processing model development and
deployment are removed it lets you build
machine learning models using standard
sequel and without the need to move your
data for external training and
evaluation first new cake's data
scientist did a quick sample of the
transform clickstream data for this
model she wanted to look at top-line all
products per day clickstream volume so
they needed to apply a quick
transformation to group all of the
clicks by day no problem with bakeware
ml the data scientist can create various
model types including regression
clustering and XG boost in this case she
used ARIMA which is built to forecast
future time series based values here she
told the model what data target to
forecasts and time series columns to use
and provided a hint regarding us-based
holidays finally she passed in the query
of clique streams that looks back to
years that prunes out the last 30 days
this model trains on two years of data
and then saves into the data set for
evaluation and serving she then used the
ML forecast option to forecast the next
30 days in the time series at a 90
percent confidence interval to verify
the model estimates she selected the
actuals from the 30 day window from
there she could plot the historical plus
forecast plus
and the lower and upper bound of the
confidence intervals this graph passes a
quick eye test you can see seasonality
changes over quarter and then surges
during the weekends once we get into the
forecast you can see that the model is
within three of the four week windows
and barely misses week one even though
it saw an upward trend with an
end-to-end workflow in place the data
scientists can go back into additional
EDA for outliers and errors and then
persist these results back to the
warehouse and or share the model for
serving with a top-line model in place
new kicks can move on to additional
models like per store and per product
based forecasting problem solved in this
demo we showed you how new kicks
efficiently extended a bigquery data
warehouse to create a demand forecasting
model by utilizing various
transformation patterns flex Lots
federated queries GIS and machine
learning functions check out these links
to learn more and get started with
building your cloud native data
warehouse on Google Cloud
[Music]